>>Eric Chu: My name is Eric Chu. And I'm responsible
for the Android Developer Ecosystem. To help
us get started this session, let me assemble
the context for Android Market. We launched
Android Market about 2 1/2 years ago with
the first Android device. Our simple goal
was to connect developers from around the
world with great products, with users from
around the world who were interested in these
products. During this period we saw tremendous,
tremendous growth in adoption by carriers,
by OEMs, by developers, and by users in the
Android community. But for today what we want
to do is talk about Android Market from the
perspective of developers.
So there are four things we wanted to cover
today. The first one is customers. So who
are these users downloading applications from
the Android Market? What are they interested
in?
My goal is to help you get more information
to help you better plan your target and better
plan your business. Second thing is distribution
tools. It's very important for us to make
sure that Android Market provides the best
tools to make it easy for you to distribute
your products. So I'm going to share with
you a few things that we've been working on.
Third is merchandising. Android Market is
a marketplace. It's important for us to make
sure that we do everything we can to help
you merchandise your product on Android Market.
So I think you're going to like what some
of the things we're announcing and launching
today.
And the last thing is monetization. We actually
have investing and increasing investment in
this area over the last six months. So I'm
going to share with you some of the earlier
results we've seen based on the investments
we've been making.
So why don't we get started? First is customers.
Who are these customers?
Yesterday at the keynote we announced that
we're now activating 400,000 devices on a
daily basis. I'm sure many of you agree that's
a very, very impressive number. But what's
even more impressive, if you look at the growth
rate, in terms of how fast we're adding these
new users. Last year at Google I/O, we announced
we were adding 100,000 new users on a daily
basis. So what that means is, within a span
of 12 months, we quadrupled the number of
new users we added on a daily basis. Not only
are we adding a lot of new users every day,
we're increasing the rate in terms of adding
new users. But, having a larger install base,
while it's important, is only part of the
equation. The other important part of the
equation is are these users actually downloading
applications?
So we went back and looked at 2010 data. What
we found is that, by the middle of 2010 last
year, the number of applications users on
Android Market were downloading already exceeded
all the application downloads in the previous
year and a half. By the end of last year,
only a few months ago, Android Market users
download eight times as many apps that they've
done previously. So we've seen tremendous
growth in terms of these users's interested
in downloading applications.
And we're looking at 2011 data, we're seeing
the same pattern. By the end of Q1 we exceeded
the first three quarters in terms of download
numbers compared to the Q1 this year. And,
looking at data today, as you watched the
data yesterday, we exceeded the number of
users download in all of 2010. So, as you
can see, the increase that we're seeing in
terms of device activation is clearly translating
into rapid increase in application consumption.
And that's good news.
Now let's take a look at where the action
is coming from. So the first thing we looked
at is, in Q1 of this year, if you look at
the U.S. numbers compared to the same period
last year, we activated three times as many
devices as we did last year in the same period.
That's very impressive. But what's even more
impressive, if you look at all the device
activation outside the U.S., we activated
18 times as many devices as we did outside
the U.S. market. So the international market
is really, really picking up. This is thanks
to, for example, in Korea. We saw within the
same period Korea activated 50 times as many
devices as they did in Q1 of last year. Japan
40 times followed by U.K., Germany, and France.
All these countries seeing a huge increase
in device activation. To put in context, last
year at this time we activated about 70-plus
percent of the devices we activated were from
the U.S. Today about over 60% of the devices
we activated are outside the U.S.
So, if you guys have been focusing only on
the U.S. market, it's time to pay attention
to the international market.
We've seen the same pattern from a consumption
perspective. U.S. currently represents about
40% of the application consumption on Android
Market followed closely by Korea and Japan.
The key piece of information I want you guys
to take away is that U.S. is definitely growing
very, very fast.
It continues to be a very important market.
But even more important is to pay attention
to international market.
We also took a look at the download of applications
by users on different versions of -- device
with different version of Android. Contrary
to common sense -- and, for those of you who
are familiar with install base -- majority
of the devices we have currently running within
the Android Market are running either 2.1
or 2.2.
However, what we're seeing is that Android
2.3, Gingerbread devices, these users are
downloading on the average more than two times
as many apps as the users running 2.2 or 2.1.
On Honeycomb those users are downloading more
than 2 1/2 times the applications. So not
only should you pay attention to the size
install base. It's also important to pay attention
to the behavior of these users and really
understand which group of users are heavy
consumption applications.
So now let's go in a little further and look
at what's happening within the different categories
of applications. So, if you look at overall
in terms of overall application across all
the different categories, what we're seeing
is that entertainment, games, or tools continue
to have largest applications. Developers love
to build these type of products. The good
news is users also like these products. So
games, entertainment, tools remain the three
most popular types of applications people
are downloading. But what we're also seeing
is that media -- audio, video, travel, logo
in these areas -- these are also extremely
popular with users. So what we've seen there
is that users gravitate toward branded products.
They gravitate toward branded services that
access the premium services. In this case
fewer applications account for larger percentage
of download.
Now we look a look at pay apps alone. Games,
clearly, is the number one leader. Android
users love games. And arcade is the most popular
across all different game categories. The
other thing we're finding interesting is that
we find Android users to be more -- at least
we think they're a little more technically
savvy. They're very interested in purchasing
tools and utilities that add additional capabilities
to their devices. Ever since we launched Live
Wallpaper, the combination of Live Wallpaper,
widgets, alternative launchers, we see the
personalization propel into the number three
spots. And we see -- as a matter of fact,
one of the developers in our sandbox has an
alternative launcher. And, you know, he launched
a product I think maybe a couple months ago.
He's extremely, extremely happy with the number
of downloads and the amount of revenue he's
generating from his application.
The last thing I want to mention on this slide
is productivity. Productivity has remained
one of the top categories on Android Market
since the beginning. But in this category,
what we see is that a few applications, documents-to-go
or exchange connectivity, represent the bulk
of the revenue. So in these cases these are
not applications that are $1 or $2. These
are relatively expensive applications. They're
doing really well in terms of the number of
downloads and also doing very well in terms
of revenue.
So I hope the information we share with you
is going to help you better understand, you
know, who some of the users are and what they're
interested in. And our goal is to help you
to better target your investment and take
advantage of the install base that we have.
So the next thing I want to talk about is
distribution tools. As I mentioned earlier,
this is a very important area for us. We want
to make sure that Android Market makes it
the very marketplace to make it easy for to
you distribute your applications. But, before
I go into it, I think it's also important
for me to also spend a few minutes to address
some of the common questions we get from developers
in terms of how they should package their
application for Android and Android Market
for distribution.
So the number one most common question we
get from developer is what advice do we have
for them in how they should package their
Android application with different versions
of Android?
Well, this is precisely why we make this information
available on developer.Android.com. As you
can see, Android 2.2 and 2.1 represent the
bulk of the install base. If you look at the
number of these entries we've done over the
last 2 1/2 years, we've been very aggressive
innovating and adding new features on a very
rapid pace. But what we've seen is that our
carrier and OEM partners are actually keeping
pace with us. We've been looking at this pie
chart, actually, for about 12 months. At any
given point, we typically see two releases
of Android being dominant at any given point.
So our partners are actually tracking with
us and updating their devices with the latest
release of Android as quick as they can. And,
in case you missed the announcement yesterday,
many of our top partners -- Verizon, T-Mobile,
Sprint, Samsung, LG, HTC -- all announced
that they're committed to upgrade their devices
for 18 months to the latest release of Android.
What that means for you guys is that you can
count on even more rapid convergence to the
latest release of Android and give you a great
platform to innovate. However, what it also
means from a developer perspective is that
Android is a platform that should give you
a lot of flexibility. You can easily build
your application with one binary and, because
of a commitment to backward compatibility,
that application should work across many different
versions of the OS. In addition, we also are
allowed to use features like Reflection that
allows you to have one binary that can both
take advantage of new APIs on new devices
at the same time as still run on Android device
running older versions.
Another question we get asked a lot is what
about all the different screen sizes?
Again, this information is available on developer.Android.com.
Two screen sizes, HVGA, a wide screen, represents
93% of volume. As a matter of fact, wide VGA
represents over 75% of the volume.
If you go to developer.Android.com, you get
all the details. What that means for you,
as a developer, it means that, if you decide
to build your apps in such a way to target
only a few screen sizes, you can easily do
that and get to the bulk of the install base.
But why limit yourself?
Android, as a framework, actually, has a lot
of facility, makes it easy to help your application
scale and look good on devices with different
screen sizes. You can easily build your application
as a single binary with a single resource
and have it run on many different devices.
For those developers who -- you know, in some
cases, a lot of these cases are game developers
who want to have a lot more precise control.
They want to have the perfect graphics for
screen sizes, we also provided a facility
for them to have a single binary that's supported
by multiple research bundles.
What about 3D? Many of you ask can I count
on OpenGL ES 2.0?
The answer is yes. About 90% of the -- over
90% of the devices today that are touching
Android Market support OpenGL ES 2.0. You
can absolutely take advantage of these advanced
reading capabilities. Or, again, the framework
provides the ability to build your application
in such a way you can run across both types
of devices.
So many of the developers today are already
taking advantage of this capability. They're
running many applications on many devices.
So I decided to go to Android Market and look
for a few examples. The first example I found
was Pulse news. It's a popular news application.
This developer built an application to run
on Android 1.5 and higher devices. Make it
-- it's designed to run on all the different
screen sizes of Android devices, all the densities.
So, consequently, this application runs on
99% of the devices that access Android Market.
As a matter of fact, this developer had never
seen Android 3.1. So we just launched Android
3.1 yesterday. And Pulse news worked flawlessly
on Android 3.1.
Now let's shift gears a little bit. Let's
talk about gaming. Rovio Angry Birds -- Angry
Birds Rio is a popular 3D game. In this case,
this developer decided to target an application
for Android 1.6 and higher. This supports
small, normal, large screen sizes, three densities.
And, in this case, because they decided not
to support Android 1.5 devices, which is a
very, very small segment of the population,
Angry Birds Rio runs on 97% of the devices.
So Kenneth Lui is an Angry Bird addict. I
know he's going to show us what we've been
doing with Angry Birds here.
>>Kenneth Lui: Thanks, Eric. We're going to
switch over here. So this will give you a
visual of what Eric was talking about. Rovio
decided that they wanted to address a wide
range of users. And, in order to do that,
they needed to address -- can you switch this?
Let me play it upside down. There we go. So
-- I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
>>Eric Chu: I thought you knew how to play
this game upside down.
>>Kenneth Lui: So they needed to address a
wide variety of different devices. As you
can see here, we have, coming up from the
HTC tattoo here, all these devices support
1.6 and above. We're ranging from QVJ devices
to HVGA to wide VGA all the way up to the
Galaxy tablet and wide zoom screen sizes.
Because of the way I developed this application,
as you can see, it runs very optimally across
all these different devices. What's even more
important to note, I think, is that, when
they developed and deployed this application,
many of these devices already existed. So
it ran on those devices.
But, since that application has been deployed,
many new devices have also appeared on the
market as well. Obviously, you do need to
do some testing on some of these devices,
which they've actually done a very good job
of scaling to different devices. But it shows
that you can actually use one APK without
having to target a specific device and be
able to address a large range of devices.
And I think the result shows, because a lot
of people downloaded lots and lots, and also
the rating is very good from the users as
well.
>>Eric Chu: So this Zoom tablet is running
Android 3.1, right?
>>Kenneth Lui: Yes.
>>Eric Chu: So Rovio had never seen this happen
before?
>>Kenneth Lui: Right. We put it on, and it
worked.
>>Eric Chu: Great. Thank you. So another application
I want to highlight is some of you may say,
what about more sophisticated games?
So Glu has a game called Gun Bros. It's a
3D multi-user game. And, in this case, they
decided performance is really important for
them. So they target 2.0 and higher. They
target screen sizes normal, large, extra large.
They know about tablets. They are going to
design an application to also go on a tablet.
And, in this case, their application with
multiple resource bundle -- because, in this
case, they really want to have more control
of the graphical asset on different screen
sizes -- runs on 94% of devices. So, even
for a very high-end 3D game, it's absolutely
possible for you to build your application
with, in this case, with additional resource
bundle and support many, many different devices.
So stepping back, what we really tried to
do with Android as a platform is give you
the flexibility to build your application
for extremely, extremely wide distribution
both in terms of from a geo perspective, from
a hardware capability perspective, and also
in terms of API perspective. At the same time,
we also recognize that there are developers
who want very precise control and precise
targeting how they deploy the application.
So this is where Android Market comes in.
So Android Market is designed to complement
Android as a platform, working hand in hand
to make it extremely easy for you to, number
one, from a business targeting perspective,
target your application to run on all countries,
subsequent countries, or any of the carriers
within these countries. At the same time,
from a capabilities perspective, we also give
you the built-in flexibility to, if you choose
to, target specific OS versions, specific
screen sizes, specific OpenGL versions or
whatnot. So we give you a lot of control on
how you can target your application. However,
we've also heard requests from a lot of developers,
from those developers who really want to target
an application, they really want to have more
tools to help them understand. If they choose
to only, let's say, support two or three versions
of Android platform, what devices will be
available to them?
So I'm pleased to announce starting today
on the Android Market site, based on the manifest
of your applications -- you get to declare
and define it -- you can easily upload your
publication, either publish or draft, see
all the devices that your application would
be visible to. You also have the option, if
you want to, to basically opt out of some
of the devices. So, Kenneth, why don't you
walk through and show us what this looks like.
>>Kenneth Lui: Sure. What you see on the screen
here is the developer publishing site. We're
looking at an application which is timeriffic.
If I scroll down to where some of the target
options are, we have the country and carrier
targeting Eric talked about earlier. We also
now, in addition, you see a section called
supported devices. Within supported devices,
it will tell you what screen layouts are supported.
It also gives you an account. If you notice,
there's a number here which says this application
is available to over 388 devices. So we can
actually click into it and see what those
exact devices are. So, if I click into it,
it will be listed by manufacturer. Each manufacturer
has different models. And let's pick one of
these. Let's say Acer show more. And I can
actually see what devices are included in
that group of devices -- group that this application
is available to.
I can also choose to exclude them. But let
me show you another application that -- timeriffic
in draft mode that we're about to launch.
So this is an application that actually has
a higher platform requirement. It's the same
screen size layout. But you see that, in addition
to what we saw earlier, we have now a smaller
number of devices. So now this application
is available for 346 devices. This is a paid
version of the one that I just showed you.
Now, if I go into show devices, we see the
same lists. But, if I click on to, for example,
Dell, you will see that there are Dell devices
that are supported up there. But there are
also devices that are not supported. So the
Dell, for example, in this case, is a 1.5
device. And it tells you it is unsupported
because of the manifest settings. I can also,
for example, manually -- let's say, if I wanted
to for some reason exclude the Dell Streak,
click on exclude. Now I have automatically
excluded devices as well as manually excluded
devices as well.
So now you see that, yes, the numbers 346
devices. It will also tell you how many devices
are manually filtered as well.
>>Eric Chu: Thank you, Kenneth.
Another feature many have developed applications
for, in some cases, developers may have multiple
versions of the application for a particular
product. They may have one version supporting
Android 2.1, 2.2, and another version supporting
a tablet.
Starting in June, we're going to be launching
a new version called Multiple APK. It allows
developers to have different versions, different
screen sizes, different text formats, all
listed under a single product listing.
[ Applause ]
>>Eric Chu: You guys like this one better
than the other one?
[ Laughter ]
>>Eric Chu: Anyway, Android Market will automatically
deliver the right APK to the right device.
What you also get as a developer is that all
the user ratings, comments, billing, will
all be aggregated in the product. And, again,
this will be available in June.
The next thing that we can -- get asked a
lot, Android users love gaming, as I mentioned
earlier. And as Android goes into tablet space
and if you look at some of the great games
that were shown in the sandbox, these are
extremely high-resolution games. In many cases,
they are ports coming from consoles. These
ports take up a lot of space.
Starting in June, we're also going to increase
the size of support from currently 50 megabytes
to four gigabytes. Android Market will manage
for you the different pieces you upload, the
application, plus the resource for the application.
All of it will be hosted on Android Market.
So for some of you who have been dealing with
secondary download, we're going to take care
of that for you and we'll download all the
pieces into the Android devices.
[ Applause ]
>>Eric Chu: The next thing is, now that your
app is published, we will also want to make
it extremely easy for you to start setting
up a marketing campaign for your products.
So yesterday, we announced one-click integration
with AdMob, which makes it extremely easy
for you right from the Android Market portal
to launch and initiate setup of an AdMob campaign
for your application.
The integration doesn't touch your application.
But what it does is it's smart enough to send
the right information, like your application
management's information to AdMob to help
make sure that you can set up your campaign
to target the right devices to support your
application.
And, again, this was launched yesterday.
The last thing I want to talk about is, now
that your application is published, you want
to know how it is doing.
So six weeks ago, we launched application
stats. What it does is give you a comprehensive
view of the download performance of your application
across different countries, different languages,
different OS, different screen sizes.
What we also provide is how your application
does compare to same application -- application
in the same category.
In addition, three weeks ago, we launched
monthly sales reporting. Our goal there is
to give you the ability to be able to download
monthly sales report so you can load into
your own system, load in your own spreadsheet,
do your own analysis, do your own tax reporting
and whatnot. So three years ago, we launched
with the month of March. I'm happy to announce,
if you go to your pub site, we now have sales
reports all the way back to January 2010.
[ Applause ]
>>Eric Chu: So as you see, we, have done a
lot of work investing in, one, making it easy
for you to manage in how you distribute an
application. At the same time, we're also
invested in giving you more and more information
how you manage your business. You can expenditure
us to continue to invest in this area.
The next thing I want to talk about is merchandising.
As I mentioned earlier, Android Market is
a marketplace. It's important for us to do
everything we can to make it easy for you
to merchandise your product.
So a few months ago, we launched Android Market
on the Web site. And our goal there is, number
one, we want to increase the service area,
make it easier for us and make it possible
for us to merchandise and showcase even more
products. At the same time, we want to provide
a convenient landing place where you promote
your applications. You can promote your application
either direct with clicks to the device, the
Android Market on the device, or you can direct
them to the Web site, where users can easily
check out your application, initially purchase
a download, and have the application pushed
onto your device.
We know there's a lot more we can do.
Let me walk you through some of the things
we are launching today.
Many of you are familiar with the list "just
in." That's how a new application starts.
You go to just in. These are more adventurous
users who are always looking for latest applications,
will find the applications, download it, play
with it, make some comments.
If I were a developer, I wouldn't stop there.
I would be thinking about what should I be
doing to drive more eyeballs to my application.
This is extremely important, because unless
you generate some velocity to generate downloads,
you're not going to make it to other lists.
You should also think about viral marketing.
Look at who you can partner with, look at
affiliates and whatnot, what you can do to
generate more eyeballs for your application.
But last, but not least, it's absolutely critical
to pay attention to the comments and feedback
from users and update your application be
frequently. Those can help propel you to the
more interesting list or potentially really
damage your ability to get eyeballs for your
applications.
Now, if you're a user, if you're a developer
that has multiple products on the Android
Market, you also get the benefit that on the
apps detail page of each application, we also
showcase other applications from the same
developer. But what if you are a brand-new
developer, you never launched any application
on the Android Market. How do you get your
-- how do you find a way, you know, to get
above all the noise, since we have thousands
and thousands of applications coming into
the Android Market on a weekly basis?
So I'm pleased to announce, starting today,
we're adding a new list on the Android Market
Web page, top page, called "trending." Trending
is aimed at showcasing those applications
that are getting a lot of downloads within
a short period. One way to think about it
is that these are the apps that are really,
really hot right now.
We are also launching two additional lists,
Top New Paid and Top New Free.
The goal of these lists is to really showcase
applications that are brand-new, less than
30 days old, but they're very popular with
users.
In addition, we're refactoring the top free
and top paid list to really focus on showcasing
applications that are getting a lot of downloads
from users.
And then last, but not least, we are also
launching a new list called "Top Grossing."
This list is aimed to showcase those revenue
generators both for initial download and in-app
billing. And so any developers with more higher-priced
applications that generate a lot of revenue
but maybe not as much download, we expect
those type of applications to show up here.
Now, in order to make this list more relevant
to each user in each country, starting today
as part of this launch, these lists will be
regionalized for the top countries around
the world. So, for example, if you are a user
in the U.S., what you see in the "Top Grossing"
list will be the top grossing applications
targeted for U.S. market. Not for Korea, not
for Japan, but for the U.S.
So, Kenneth, can you walk through what's on
-- these lists look like.
>>Kenneth Lui: Sure.
So let's start from this chart, which Eric
just went through, and go into a little more
detail about how you can actually get on these
lists. So the first one being more from a
developer, so now you have ability to actually
cross out and list your applications. So if
you're already installed, you can very easily
let the users see what other applications
you have.
Now let's get into some of the new lists.
Now, if I scroll down here, you actually see
"Trending Apps." And this is actually the
-- that's the actual list that we have right
now.
So if you look at some of these trending apps,
these are actually very, very good examples.
Google music, Web M.D., and Adidas and Groupon.
Some of these are newly launched applications,
so their actual absolute number of installs
is not very big probably right now. But they're
growing very quickly. So we're looking at
something like -- which is, let's say, in
the last day, what is the download trend of
these applications.
So if we show acceleration, then these applications
will actually get into this list.
Now if you see something like Groupon, Groupon
is an existing application, but they just
posted a major release. So even if it is an
existing application, you can actually get
onto the trending list as well if you are
generating a lot of installs. So that's what
the trending is. And this application shows
that.
Now, if we go further into the top new and
-- paid and free, you can see that now we
actually have a numbered list as well. So
these are actually -- it says number one,
Robot Unicorn; number two, Talking Lila, the
Fairy. So we actually have ranked lists in
the top new and top paid. If we click on one
of them, you actually see a longer list of
applications. Again, they all have a ranking
next to them.
And we actually show these apps that are in
the top new and top -- Top New Free and paid.
What this is trending is a day. Top new looks
into applications that are not older than
30 days and actually showing a weekly download
of installations and putting them into this
rank list.
Continuing on to the lists, now, if your application
does really well and continues to do well
beyond the seven days, then we have the top
free and top paid applications. So now we
actually make it into this list in terms of
installations. And then, finally, top grossing,
which is the sale of the application.
Now, Eric also mentioned that while we are
looking at the English version of this Web
site, I also started another session. Now,
if we look at this session, this is showing
the Korean list that users in Korea would
actually see.
So, first of all, it's localized. And then
also, if we pay attention to what the top
lists are listing, you see some of them are
global, English applications. But if we actually
scroll down, for example, Kakaotalk, a couple
others that I don't know how to pronounce.
But these are Korean applications. What's
important to note is we're not filtering these
applications based on the country, but these
are actual behavior of users downloading applications
in these countries and that's how we're computing
that list. So it is locally relevant for the
users in those countries.
>>Eric Chu: Thank you.
So in addition to these top lists that we
make available at the top pages in Android
Market Web site, we also have done some work
in the details by page of each application
and cross down of the applications. So there's
two new lists that we're introducing. The
first one -- the first list is really aimed
at showcasing applications that are similar,
related to the applications that you're looking
at. The second is targeted at companion applications.
Users who download this application also download
these other applications.
Kenneth, can you show us a little what this
looks likes.
>>Kenneth Lui: Sure.
Now, I'm actually looking at a specific example
of an application, which is SlideIT Keyboard.
Within the app detail page, if I look at the
left-hand side, number one, I have the Murph
developer, which we looked at before. And
then we have a list of applications here.
Users who looked at the SlideIT keyboard,
also looked at Thumb key, smart keyboard,
better keyboard. That's what people are comparing
and kind of what fits them the most.
If I look at the list below that, it also
says, "Users who install this also install."
So these are some of the -- you know, in addition
to the application that the users installed,
they also installed these applications. So
it makes sense, because now these are actually
all language packs for this keyboard.
Just to give you one more example, on the
Zillow page, for example, you will see that
visitors who viewed this also viewed Trulia,
so people are deciding which to use. Also
users who installed this application looked
at Homes.com, Zip Realty, Real Estate Answers
as well. So they're likely to have both of
those applications.
So now there's more ways to actually -- in
relation to the users, what they're installing,
also recommending some applications for them
that they might consider.
>>Eric Chu: Thank you. In addition to these
new lists, our team will continue to look
for great amounts showcase in terms of editorial
featuring. The last thing I want to mention
-- one thing I want to mention is personal
recommendations.
In June, we're also planning to launch a new
list on the top page which is aimed at really
showcasing users applications they might be
interested in based on applications they downloaded
before.
Kenneth, can you quickly show us what we have
here?
>>Kenneth Lui: Okay. Already talked about
featuring, which talked about editorial list
of applications.
If I switch into another page, you actually
see this is the "my library" tab. Here's a
user who's very interested in real estate.
And also in golf applications.
So if I go back and see what the personal
recommendations are, let's scroll down, past
the trending list.
In the section that's called apps for you,
you'll see there are other applications like
ScoreMobile. It thinks you have downloaded
some sports and golf applications. Real estate
options: Homes.com, Century 21. Those might
be also applications that you might be interested
in as well. These are things looking more
specifically to that user, based on what you
have as a portfolio of applications that you
have downloaded, here are some additional
sets of applications that you might be interested
in.
>>Eric Chu: Thanks.
As you can see, we went from a few lists that
we had before to showcasing applications to
now 12 lists.
And this, we believe, will go a long way to
really showcase many different applications
based on different life cycles, what is a
brand-new -- whether it's a brand-new application
or an application getting downloaded right
now, or an application that's been really
popular for a while, we have a list that really
showcases these great applications.
But we think there's more we can do. We think
there's more we can do in terms of really
helping users quickly find what are some of
the best of the best applications on the Android
Market.
We also think there are things we can do to
really give developers recognition for those
developers who are committed to Android and
invested in a consistent track record of building
great applications.
So I'm pleased to announce, starting today,
we're launching Editor's Choice for Android
Market. So Editor's Choice is aimed at providing
consumers information and making it easier
for them to find the best Android applications
on the marketplace.
In addition, we're also going to be launching
the top developer badge. So Top Developer
is aimed at recognizing those developers who
have a strong track record on Android, and
they've consistently built great applications.
And we want to give them indication so that
when a user is looking at applications from
these developers, we want to provide a little
bit more information to help users feel comfortable
that these are the developers they can trust,
they can download applications from.
Kenneth, can you show us what it looks like.
>>Kenneth Lui: Right. So looking at these
applications, if we look into the details
below the icon, you can see that some of these
are actually -- has the Editor's Choice, as
well as the Top Developer.
So a few of these applications actually have
those. So, for example, if I look at -- in
this example -- Amazon Mobile, that's a top
developer. And then also -- it's also an Editor's
Choice application as well.
We also have a section here which lists all
the current Editor's Choice. So if we click
on that, you'll see a list of applications
that have been selected editorially as the
Editor's Choice applications.
>>Eric Chu: Great. Thanks.
So as part of the launch today, we started
with a set of applications that we actually
spent a lot of time looking at and making
sure these are some of the best applications
that run on many devices. We also spent a
lot of time looking at many developers that
are currently on the Android Market and trying
to pick out those developers that have a great
track record.
In the coming months, we'll plan to continue
to look for more and more applications to
add to this list and more and more developers
to add to the top developer list.
So to sum it up, if you look at, you know,
from a merchandising perspective, we've done
a lot of work to increase the real estate
in terms of how we promote applications. We've
made this list -- these lists relevant based
on each country. And we are also providing
recognition for developers' great apps and
those great apps that we think users really
look at downloading.
All of this is live on Android Market right
now. And within the next 30 days or so, we're
also going to be bringing these capabilities
to the Android Market (inaudible) device.
With that, I'm going to bring Paul Montoy-Wilson
up to show you what it will look like on the
device.
>>Paul Montoy-Wilson: My name is Paul Montoy-Wilson,
and I'm a product manager on Android Market.
Yesterday, at the keynote, we announced there
are over 200,000 applications on Android Market.
With so many applications, we are working
so hard to help users find and install more
great applications. What this means is there's
an opportunity to get your great applications
in more places on the phone.
I'd like to give you a demo of that.
Am I not strong enough? Oh, a little too strong.
Oh, I got it. Perfect.
All righty, so with that, I'm on the home
page of Android Market. And we had an updated
feature section to highlight the greatest
applications. From the feature page, I can
easily swipe to view the categories. And also
access the top lists.
In addition to the top charts that are currently
available on Android Market, I'm excited to
say that the lists Eric just announced will
also be available, like the top new charts.
It's faster and easier to explore more applications,
which means users will find more and install
more applications.
My dad just bought his first Android phone
and has never installed an app before. When
he opens up Android Market for the first time,
it's going to be a great place for him to
check out the Editor's Choice apps, an essential
set of some of the best apps on Android Market.
For me, I am an avid app user, and so what
I like to do is, every morning when I wake
up, I like to swipe over to the top new charts
and check out to see which apps are new and
popular.
I was excited to see and discover ESPN's new
live application that streams ESPN 360.
We have redesigned the app details page and
brought screen shots to the top to highlight
your most valuable assets.
In addition, we have added more applications
from this developer directly on the details
page so users can continue to browse.
When I am ready to install this application,
the download is just a click away. We have
worked hard to streamline the browse purchase
and download experience so users will find
an install more applications.
I am excited to see how this new Android Market
client for the phone will help you be successful
on Android.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>>Eric Chu: So the last section we want to
cover is monetization. As I mentioned earlier,
this is an area that we have been increasing
investment over the last six months.
And what we're seeing is we're already starting
to see the fruit of our labor.
If you look at our 2011 Q1 revenue compared
to the same period last year for the U.S.,
we saw a 3x increase in Android market revenue.
But what's even more amazing is when if you
look at the increase in revenue outside of
the U.S. We saw 30x increase in revenue. In
countries like UK, Germany and France, we
saw 7 to 8 times increase compared to the
same period last year. In Japan, with the
support of carriers such as KDDI, Docomo,
we saw a 100x increase in revenue in Japan
compared to the same period.
And we think one of the key things we need
to continue to invest in to really drive the
increase in revenue is to increase the number
of buyers in Android Market.
So over the last four quarters or so we have
already seen a six and a half times increase
in Android Market buyers from same time last
year compared to this year.
So a few things we are doing to further drive
that growth. Number one, at Google I/O last
year, Android Market was available for buyers
in 14 countries. In September, we increased
that number to 32 countries.
I'm pleased to announce over the next week
or so we'll be introducing Android Market
for buyers in 99 additional countries. That
puts a total of 131 countries where people
can buy your products.
[ Applause ]
>>Eric Chu: The other area that we have been
investing in is direct carrier billing. For
you as a developer, you don't have to do anything.
Carrier billing is just a form of payment
underneath that you don't have to worry about.
Just like a credit card, just like Visa and
Mastercard. As we add additional carriers,
you get that for free.
We have already integrated with AT&T, T*Mobile,
Sprint. We're also integrated with a few carriers
in Japan and we are already seeing great results.
When we look at one of the major U.S. carriers
that we integrated with, direct carrier billing
represents approximately 50% of the sales
transactions. That means U.S. users are definitely
using carrier billing as a way to buy applications.
When you look at what's happening in Asia,
the result is even more dramatic. Within a
short period of time after we launched carrier
Building billing, for this particular carrier
we saw sales transactions double.
The last thing I want to talk about in this
area is my personal favorite. So 45 days ago
we launched in-app billing on Android Market.
We're starting to see a few applications take
advantage of in-app billing, but what's really
interesting is that right now, these few applications
represent 14% of the average daily revenue
in Android market. A few applications.
In that billing application based on the data
we are seeing right now, monetized 25 times
more than the counterpart on the paid app
side. And you just heard we launched the top
grossing list. If you go to the list on the
Web site, you will find nine of the top ten
grossing applications, and these are brand-new
applications considering we just launched
in-app billing. Nine of the top ten applications
are in-app billing enabled -- sorry, nine
of the top ten games are in-app billing enabled.
So if you have not looked at in-app billing,
I highly, highly recommend to you take some
time to check that out.
So we shared a lot of information with you.
We shared a lot of data, we shared a lot of
information with you in terms of new things
we have done. So let me kind of try and bring
it all together.
If you are building an application for Android
Market, one of the first thing you think about
is make sure it's a great application. Make
sure this application utilizes all the great
features on Android platform. Make sure the
application looks great on those devices.
Each user on their device are always looking
for the best application on their device,
so they are not necessarily interested in
ports.
At the same time, you should really think
about broad distribution. We have done a lot
of work to make it easy for to you address
90-plus percent of the installed base. Take
advantage of that.
Make sure you think about pricing. You need
to price it relative to your competition.
It's not how much you think your app is worth.
It's how much the user is willing to pay relative
to all the other products that are available
both on Android Market and on the Android
mobile apps store.
Remember I mentioned it's extremely important
when launch an application that those few
initial ratings, comments could really either
make you or break you. Make it easy. Assume
you have a great application. Make it easy
for them to rate and provide feedback for
your application and that will help propel
you into some of these new lists that we have.
Immediately after you launch a product, really
think about marketing. We have done a lot
of good work in surfacing a lot of lists to
make it easy to promote your application,
but we need help from you to make sure you
rise above the noise and get into these lists.
It's important to monitor use of feedback.
As I mentioned earlier, respond to them and
timely update. And that's important in the
beginning, in the middle and throughout the
process. What you definitely should not do
is launch a product prematurely. We have seen
cases where developers launch a product prematurely,
get bad ratings, and they have a tough time
digging their way out of it.
It's also important not to require excessive
permissions. Where you require permissions,
especially those that seem not as intuitive,
help users understand why in description.
Where you don't need the permission, don't
ask for it.
And it's important to take a look in general
across all applications in that category and
not overprice.
So I hope you found the information we shared
with you useful.
I hope you find the new features that we are
launching today and launching soon also useful
for you.
From the Android team, our goal and our success
really lies with you. Your success is our
success.
What we think about every day is what can
we do to increase the number of downloads
of your applications to users, what can we
help you do to monetize more your investment
with Android.
Your feedback is also important to us. Your
feedback helps us prioritize what we need
to work on first so keep those coming.
So with that, thank you for being here.
[ Applause ]